Nicke vials awkward run-in with Andi  Dorfman at New York Fashion Week  just when we were getting over this if  you weren't in love with me I'm just not  sure why why you made love I don't even  more awkwardness happened when Nick ran  into Andi at the Badgley Mischka Fashion  Show in NYC on Tuesday a source tells E  team Nick kept very close tabs on his  former flame appearing quote  desperate trying to get the former  bachelorettes attention apparently Andi  wasn't having it so she upped and left  the scene  Byrne neither Nick nor Andi have tweeted  about the cringe-worthy moment but Nick  did send out a cryptic tweet on Sunday  saying I miss you so much it hurts  sometimes  you